how's it going bros my name is peter pan
so I watched Martin in the little wood
and he showed up this awesome cool
device and I was like I want to try
night so it's kind of like a tiny little
connect that you place in front of you
then you you put your head out and
you're like well and then you flip
yourself off that's great
that's always what I wanted to do in
video games and break all my cyborg
fingers
thank you I'll sit a bit more there you
go that it's working a lot better
[Music]
I can jiggle my fingers jazz hands jazz
hands so I can move all my fingers kind
of ow there we go
peace peace out brother yeah how about a
brofist bro freest can i brokerage
myself I guess no I well you can't have
everything in life oh yeah yeah
it's a party huh huh it's a party dance
dance dance dance break all your fingers
girl put the halo Robo girl all right
you want to be pink baby there you go
down and smother [ __ ] now dance all
right you're a blue [ __ ]
there you go this is awesome all right
I'll let you people yell oh oh you're
all so kawaii how do I grab that one
thank you
hey girl brother whoo it's a party I
actually have friends for the first time
I know you'll all die mr. blue come back
I love you why is blue so sad why are
you so sad mr. blue don't be so damn emo
talked about this mr. blue haha [ __ ]
ain't no party pooper in my party never
won is it alright let me see if I can
fish left 100 bitch-slap that's right
pimp slap whoo dance dance dance dance
dance that's right
dance [ __ ] Oh pinkie what are
you doing you don't dance that's not a
hat damn it
feel so creepy with my little hands like
hey dance my children dance my next one
oh it's a little flower Oh what okay
that's kind of cool it's just not
working that well
oh it grows out of new one oh it's a new
color it's not working that well but
it's pretty [ __ ] cool all the cool
kids in my school said I would never do
cool stuff in front of a computer well I
got me now plucking leaves out of a
flower how badass am i huh
yeah that's right I like I can dip them
in my in the water splash splash splash
splash oh hey and you want a flower Oh
No take it take it damn it what is that
alright we have another game here it's
called collider it looks pretty cool all
right so I'm hands flying in space
dolphin this is what rebeccablack meant
with the video dolphin hand
dolphin hands for laughs I don't know
what I'm doing I love it
this is [ __ ] cool I don't know what's
going on but I have space powers wait do
I take the ball and then charge it go
back and all that booty taking all that
booty girl charge in my balls I'm
destiny Wow all right now he works a lot
better I don't want it what I did
brofist my balls I don't know what's
okay Illuminati I'm sorry oh I'll give
you hand jobs please don't kill me Satan
this is so [ __ ] cool I'm being such a
nerd here but like it's [ __ ] cool all
right here's our chance
chop it have it ha damn it hand jobs all
the way oh my god
that's really [ __ ] cool let's try it
some more games let's do some sculpt
ring we all know I have the skills all
right here we go
let's sculpture that okay this is I
don't know what we're making here but
I'm guessing some kind of demon baby
perhaps yes oh yeah bitte bitte bitte ah
people don't understand my art people
just don't understand how I'm trying to
express myself ah ah can't a towel that
I put so much effort into this art god
damn it it looks disgusting point your
finger and keep inside the green area
all right whoa hello
all right you know what that's okay what
am I gonna do with this square
I'm gonna stick this finger exactly I
don't know was that kind of game that's
right ah tolerance weren't numbered in
Tony's talents do you like to shoot
first and ask well he's just like this
shoot yeah I get a day oh god I shot her
I didn't mean to shoot her
I mean uh piece of [ __ ] that's right
keep shooting yeah baby pew pew thank
God and let me outside
things got it up but I was innocent then
got it alright there we go
you're welcome everyone you're welcome
finger bang bang finger bang bang Oh gig
what's going on here Oh God meet Bertha
kovalevskiy bra 36k not great at
swimming damn it why is she a mermaid
then what the [ __ ] am I looking at what
the [ __ ] I thought I was gonna finger
people this is way worse there we go
not a big deal hair gel oh yeah nothing
like oh I can't have hair gel man
she got it come on just help her already
dammit there we go let's help finally we
could have done that ages ago
okay wait she was in politics take I'll
take I'll take I'll alright so that was
that don't know what to call it but it's
pretty [ __ ] cold it's kind of
technology I'm excited but very simple
you could put it anywhere you can mount
it on your off the lift even which is
pretty damn cool looking forward to
trying some stuff out for that look
Bruce let me know what you think and
I'll stop fingering people for now hits
this guy to come over today and as
always stay awesome Russ